all right tonight we're not even through
the year one of joe biden's year one of
joe biden's presidency things are going
so poorly that even joe's biggest
defenders in the media mob their jumping
ship get this in an article biden should
not run again and he should say he won't
new york times columnist brett stevens
is back begging joe not to seek a second
term calling him quote alarmingly
incoherent if you're a democrat and
someone at the new york times calls you
alarmingly incoherent it may be time to
pack it in and meanwhile the media arm
of biden's 2020 campaign fake news cnn
they just published this article 11
democrats that could replace joe biden
in 2024 they don't even want him to run
again now the piece heavily suggests
biden will not be capable of running for
a second term it lists 11 random
democrats who could take uh the lead on
the ticket notably missing from the list
is someone who no doubt would love
another opportunity to be called madam
president without a doubt the one and
only hillary clinton is ready willing to
answer that call and according to my
next guest well media
columnist joe concha she might be their
best hope i don't think that's hope at
all here with more joe konchek fox news
contributor along with fox news
contributor as well miranda devine joe
when you really look at the list i don't
kamala p buddha
amy klobuchar
um yeah they're not exactly a a deep
bench of democrats that you can look at
at this moment that i see and i say uh
oh i'd be worried about that one
sure and then two polls sean tell the
story right 22
basically one in five voters say they
want joe biden to run in 2024. could you
imagine that number with donald trump he
was always up around 90
loyalty within his party and then when
you talk to democrats and i have i'm
from jersey after all only a smidge over
one-third want joe biden to be president
in his second term he'll be 86 at that
point so i wrote that hillary column and
let me be clear i'm not arguing that
hillary is a great candidate or likable
or authentic or has any grounding
principles i'm saying the democratic
party is when you're talking about
potential presidential candidates is
like a conference in the nfl if that
conference was made up entirely of and i
hate to say this the new york jets and
giants because hillary sees these
opponents and says well wait a minute
what's going to stop me from getting the
nomination kamala please don't make me
tackle she's at 28
bootage edge what's he going to run on
his performance of south bend mayor or
the supply chain crisis okay andrew
cuomo he's not available for comment
elizabeth warren how did she do in 2020
bernie he would be in his 90s at the end
of his second term cnn also offered phil
murphy the governor of my state here in
new jersey who barely won re-election
here it's a deep blue state gretchen
whitmer stacey abrams who's hailed for
claiming her election was stolen funny
how that works so yeah given all these
versions of the new york jets and giants
why not hillary as the democratic
nominee when you consider the
competition
miranda
yes hillary so she can lose again
spectacularly um i mean look i think
that was a hilarious column joe and it's
um
it certainly makes people interested to
think that hillary might come back and
you're right i mean the rest of the
democrat field seems to be pretty
lackluster but i think that's because
they're not listening to the people i
mean the only reason that joe biden was
voted in last time was because he was
presented as a moderate as a unifier
people are crying out for some sort of
unifying president without really
realizing that that's a mirage so maybe
if the democrats uh repudiated their
progressive their radical stances i mean
the la in in the primaries it was
incredible uh all all the ideas like
stacking the supreme court and
abolishing the electoral college and so
on these were all mainstreamed by those
candidates the democratic party has been
pulled so hard to the left that it's
become unelectable
unbelievable uh i
uh if donald trump would just
he just has to sit back let them
continue to fail then make an
announcement that he's going to
reinstate all the other policies that he
had when he was president i wouldn't do
a single interview if i was him he
doesn't even have to do a debate and
just show up and pick up the keys from
joe on his way out it would be that easy
thank you both hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else